pero tu deuda es enorme
grande solo dije que tengo un gusto
costoso eso no significa que lleve una
vida de lujo si tuvieses que
clasificarse con otros en función de un
rasgo en específico que diría sobre cómo
los ves y cómo te ven ellos para
averiguarlo reunimos a cinco
desconocidos y les pedimos que se
clasificarán en función de sus deudas y
luego reorganizarán en función de su
deuda real esto es una clasificación
mi nombre es dominique tengo 29 años y
soy creador de contenidos y nombres eric
y voy a la escuela de enfermería soy de
la y me voy a la escuela de posgrado en
dos semanas muchas felicidades hola a
todos mi nombre es ataviado yuna
creadora digital barra gestora de redes
sociales cualquier cosa que me apetezca
hacer la verdad soy lola y trabajo en el
sistema de salud mental
estamos hablando de tarjetas de crédito
y
podría decir que me encontré con una
deuda estoy en la escuela de enfermería
y tuve que conseguir prestar
estudiantiles y ustedes auto una deuda
estudiantil tarjetas de crédito acabo de
comprar mi primer auto un préstamo
personal y tarjetas de crédito y cosas
así me preocupaba mucho que fuera a
tener la mayor deuda porque me da mucha
vergüenza a endeudar me tengo más
préstamos estudiantiles que deudas
médicas tengo una cantidad decente sobre
todo la casa y los préstamos
estudiantiles de acuerdo así que soy la
única que no tiene deudas de préstamos
están preguntando si era un rolls-royce
no lo es sólo tengo es un prius híbrido
híbridos son costosos no tengo tantas
deudas personales bueno llenas y con el
labio leporino y paladar hendido así que
he tenido siete cirugías las dos más
recientes fueron una cirugía de doble
mandíbula y una rinoplastia y el seguro
no lo cubrió esa vez fue
dios mío y no resultó tan bien porque
sigo sin poder respirar bien está bien
así que en realidad necesito otra
cirugía para mí
si diría que es terrible que tengamos
tanta deuda médica y especialmente desde
que no pude realmente no pude realmente
cambiar la forma en que nací fue difícil
hablar de ello pero en cierto modo fue
terapéutico y si tienen algún tipo de
gasto que haya sido excesivo para
ustedes no soy realmente una chica muy
mimada siempre le doy un porcentaje a la
pasión por ti
es que tengo un gusto costoso las cosas
que me gustan son de gama alta es
realmente molesto definitivamente he
mejorado mucho y ya no estoy acumulando
más de lo has pagado todo no lo he hecho
hasta una mayoría de mis deudas son por
necesidad todo es una necesidad nunca he
tenido compras no deseadas bien para los
deseos y las necesidades son diferentes
un auto pagado tengo un auto que está
pagando y tienes casa no no tengo casa
cuántas casas tienes de mi propiedad
sólo una de acuerdo tierras pero solo
una casa bueno si ya tenías muchas
deudas por que compraste una casa para
hacer algún dinero con la renta
como si no estuvieras viviendo en esa
casa que tiene compre la casa en
efectivo pero hoy así que no espera que
específicamente compre la casa en
efectivo ya que préstamos para poder
invertir en otra propiedad y así puedo
ganar más dinero entonces cómo les ha
afectado mentalmente los préstamos y
todo es ya estoy estresado es que la
escuela de enfermería es dura pedí todo
este préstamo y si fracaso voy a deber
este dinero para nada y eso me asusta
demasiados a veces puedo sentir mi
estabilidad mental decayendo estoy
siendo más duro conmigo mismo así que
estoy estresado todo el tiempo 24/7
acumula muchas deudas porque no estaba
cuidando mi salud mental así que
dependía mucho de la terapia de compras
eso empeoró mi salud mental bueno cuando
oyes hablar de deudas piensas parece un
terrible hábito de gasto o algo así yo
solo compraba comida para mí y trataba
de pagar el alquiler y esas cosas sólo
trataba de llevar una vida normal yo
solo quiero seguir adelante pero todavía
tengo deudas entonces que puedo hacer es
y dejar de confiar en ellas también soy
alguien que tiene ansiedad con muchos
trabajos así que siempre estoy como
tienes que trabajar trabajar y
desgastarse y luego puedes gastar ese
dinero pero eso no es realista mi deuda
es por la universidad tengo mucha
ansiedad no podía conducir lejos de mi
casa no subo elevadores entonces tuve
que elegir la universidad más cercana
que resultó ser muy costosa creo que mi
ansiedad era tan alta que miraba a la
deuda o el dinero relacionado solo como
una carga definitivamente tengo algo con
lo que mi novia siempre está molesta me
dice siempre estás trabajando debido a
mi edad no puedo tener un trabajo sin
embargo yo siguen en realidad trabajo
todas las horas extras que pueden hacer
no paro de tener ansiedad pensando que
en un bueno pagarlas no sé qué hacer la
mitad del tiempo no mi familia bueno
realmente no es adinerada por lo que
incluso ahora tienen esta mentalidad en
la que piensan se asustan por no ser
capaces de pagar algo y a veces es
necesario endeudarse y es terrible pero
es algo que resulta inevitable
pero siento que tienes muchas deudas
porque los gastos médicos son altos mis
mayores deudas son estudiantil
pero también las cosas de la casa son
costosas así que ustedes dos están de
primera definitivamente creo que si yo
voy a mover en la universidad
comunitaria
creo que ustedes
enfermería es costosa
grande solo tengo un gusto costoso no
significa que viva una vida de lujo
donde compran comida ustedes estos
libros no bueno no dije alimentos
integrales fonso rounds o ralph yo
compro mi ropa en walmart creo que
deberías estar al final creo que
deberías ayudar al final y tú pareces
estar bastante bien para ser sincera
bueno
con esos chicos estamos de acuerdo en
que él tiene la mayor deuda porque fue a
la escuela de mir tiene en cuenta que
este es sólo el segundo año así y
búscame en 4 años y estaré aquí solo
bromeando pensé que lo tuyo sería mayor
hasta que dijiste que tu médico no es
tan costoso como tu escuela porque la de
la escuela normalmente es mucha pero no
creo que sea tanto si la médica es más
baja si decides que deberías estar donde
estás creo que deberías estar más alto
que yo de acuerdo creo que lo logramos
pero está bien creo que en realidad
hemos estado que no estemos equivocados
exacto
hola soy milk y siempre estoy buscando
maneras de vivir un estilo de vida más
ecológico así que quiero agradecer al
patrocinador de hoy lomi lomi es un
aparato revolucionario que convierte los
residuos orgánicos de la comida y los
bioplásticos aprobados por lo me
entierran rica en nutrientes es fácil de
usar y su diseño lo convierte en una
hermosa adición a su cocina así que
hagamos tierra para usarlo me lo que
tienes que hacer es llenarlo con
residuos de alimentos y pulsar el botón
para que haga su magia y descomponga tus
residuos hay tres ajustes de ciclo que
te ayudan a adaptar tus residuos y
convertirlos en tierra rica en
nutrientes y es especialmente bueno
crear abono para su jardín en casa y el
resto de las plantas con lom y puede
reducir su huella de residuos en un 50%
logrando un impacto positivo en el medio
ambiente asegúrese de consultar el
enlace en la descripción para comprar el
suyo hoy ahora volvamos al vídeo
bien en el quinto lugar tenemos a tab ya
con 23 mil 65 dólares de deuda esto va
bien yo pensaba que el más bajo tendría
como unos dos mil estamos aquí para
el cuarto lugar tenemos a lola es para
deuda de 24 mil
622 dólares y en el tercer lugar tenemos
a de la con una deuda
en el segundo lugar tenemos a eric con
una deuda de 42 mil dólares debería en
primer lugar tenemos a dominique con una
deuda de 2 millones de dólares
los que entraron escalofríos por todo el
cuerpo de su hermano prince x 2 millones
[Risas]
pero mi préstamo estudiantil fue más que
el de ustedes combinados casi 400 mil
dólares fui a chapman
estresada después de escuchar 2 millones
de dólares
estoy bien si sé que se sintieron mejor
sobre sus deudas al saber la mía pero
hay diferentes tipos de deudas a que un
préstamo para mi casa es una deuda buena
que no me preocupa la deuda médica puede
subir de ella mucho más fácil pero la
deuda estudiantil se puede considerar
como una deuda mala porque no te hará
ganar dinero por sí misma la deuda de
tarjeta de crédito diría que es de las
peores su interés es tan alto que
realmente puede empeorar y destruirte no
todavía estoy estresada por mi deuda
cada vez que hablo de ello me pongo muy
nerviosa y ansiosa bueno porque es un
tabú ser pobre y hablar de cuánto ganas
eso también es un tabú automáticamente
la gente le asigna valor a esa persona
cuando no es lo mismo durante un tiempo
estuve muy en contra de las deudas y me
perdía todo lo que hacían mis amigos
porque crecían con dinero sus padres los
traían en auto yo tenía que quedarme en
casa porque no me lo podía permitir fue
cuando mi mente cambio estoy en mis 20
tengo que hacer cosas así que estoy como
bien déjenme disfrutar y vivir mi vida
sí así es mucha gente ve y dice tienes
deuda eres irresponsable y yo pienso
amigo todo el mundo en la escuela de
medicina todos en farmacia todos los que
están en el cuidado de la salud deben
vivir pues nos está muy endeudado creo
que la deuda ya no me sorprende saber
que muchos millonarios y
multimillonarios utilizan la deuda en su
beneficio y sin embargo las personas de
clase baja se les hace sentir que es
algo malo yo la he usado para vivir una
vida normal y esa sería mi ventaja no es
diferente así que no creo que tenga que
sentirme mal por ello me comprometí
tanto con estudiar todo lo relacionado
al dinero que por eso estoy donde estoy
no es un trabajo duro ni nada parecido
sino el privilegio de aprender se
inteligente pregúntate si puedes pagarlo
pero si tienes una visión y un plan para
tener éxito endeudarte está bien en
tarjetas de crédito no bromeo no hagamos
de hagas una tarjeta de crédito pasa tu
tarjeta de crédito
en gracia el corte